este frente ha estado activo desde los
primeros días de la guerra los
comandantes aquí cuentan que cuando las
fuerzas rusas tomaron el control de
melitópol esta ciudad en el sur del país
avanzaron hacia aquí y este fue el
primer lugar donde lograron detenerlos
estos hombres son quienes protegen en la
actualidad la primera posición ucraniana
en la carretera que usan miles de
personas que es capaz de poblaciones
asediadas o en control ruso como
mariupol
los rusos están de ese lado pero están
lejos nosotros no los separan más de
cuatro kilómetros de distancia
flexibilidad yo cuando nos atacan
tratamos de escondernos que estar cerca
de la pared muy cerca del piso para
evitar que nos alcancen partes de la
munición cada cual tiene su propia
posición aquí guardamos una munición
la provincia de sap orilla en el centro
sur de ucrania tiene al menos el 70 por
ciento de su territorio en control de
las fuerzas rusas cuando se esconde el
sol es el momento más peligroso del día
para ellos dicen que primero llegan los
drones que hacen un reconocimiento y
luego empiezan los ataques desde
diferentes frentes artillería hay
bombardeos pasan los aviones y en la
ciudad de atrás que está a mis espaldas
hay pelea callejera y están las tropas
ucranianas y rusas peleando calle a
calle esquina a esquina cada uno de sus
objetos son huellas de la dureza de la
vida en el frente de batalla
para mí el día más difícil fue
probablemente el primer día porque nadie
se esperaba esto y nadie se dio cuenta
que esto le podría pasar a nuestro país
y para estos hombres no sólo están webó
su supervivencia sino la de millones de
personas cuya seguridad depende de que
esas trincheras puedan evitar que las
fuerzas rusas avancen